comprendre si le virus sras skov 2 peut
se transmettre par l'air ont été une des
plus grandes questions de la pandémie
aujourd'hui on sait que c'est possible
mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire pour
nous est-ce qu'on est automatiquement
danger une fois à l'intérieur
est-ce qu'à être à l'extérieur et sans
risque comprendre comment le virus se
transmet ne va pas nous permettre de
réduire le risque à zéro mais il peut
nous permettre de le minimiser
comment le virus se propage des cons
expire de l'air que ce soit en respirant
ou en parlant on émet des millions de
petites gouttes de liquide qui viennent
dans toutes les tailles les plus grosses
vont tomber rapidement au sol autour de
nous un peu comme la bruine
on les appelle les gouttelettes les plus
fines vont flotter dans l'air sur une
plus grande distance un peu comme de la
fumée de cigarette
on les appelle les aérosols ces deux
types de particules peuvent transporter
du virus d'une personne à l'autre
mais quand et comment reste une question
de contexte
il ya trois éléments qui peuvent
influencer ce risque la proximité qu'on
a avec une personne infectée la durée de
temps qu'on passe près de sept personnes
et la circulation l'air autour de nous
pendant qu'on est avec elle ensuite tout
est une question de probabilité
plus on est près d'une personne infectée
pendant longtemps dans un endroit où
l'air circule mal et plus on risque
d'inhaler assez de particules et du
virus qui vient avec
pour développer la maladie quels sont
les risques à l'intérieur
l'essentiel des cas de transmission de
kfw 19 se fait entre quatre murs c'est
normal on est plus près les uns des
autres
l'air circule moins bien ça laisse plus
de chances au virus de s'y accumuler on
n'est pas encore certain de la distance
que vont parcourir une particule virale
à l'intérieur d'une pièce ni même de la
durée de temps pendant laquelle elle
peut il rester en suspension
mais pour les chercheurs la meilleure
analogie reste celle de la fumée de
cigarette
c'est pour ça que c'est très important
de changer le plus régulièrement
possible l'air d'une pièce sont en
ouvrant les fenêtres sont en utilisant
un appareil qui va venir remplacer ses
terres périodiquement on peut aussi
diminuer la concentration de particules
virales dans l'air avec un purificateur
qui va venir filtrer l'air de la pièce
dans laquelle on se trouve
mais reste des doutes concernant ces
appareils parce que s'ils sont mal
installé il pourrait ne pas filtrer
l'air de l'ensemble d'une pièce ou même
créer des courants d'air qui vont
concentrer les particules virales à
certains endroits ce qui augmenterait
les risques de contracter la maladie
ce qui est certain c'est que si on est
en groupe à l'intérieur d'une pièce peu
ou pas ventilé les risques de contracter
la maladie sont réels même si on est
tous à deux mètres les uns des autres
quels sont les risques à l'extérieur à
l'extérieur le danger est moindre et le
risque de contracter la maladie d'un
passant qu'on croisera sur le trottoir
est infime
les particules virales qui se trouve en
suspension dans les aérosols vont être
rapidement dispersé par le vent et
d'autres éléments comme la lumière du
soleil la température ou même l'humidité
peuvent tout endommagé la capsule
protectrice du virus et nuire à sa
propagation
mais même à l'extérieur le risque n'est
pas inexistant les études préliminaires
ont montré que jusqu'à 6% des cas de
transmission du virus se faisait à
l'extérieur 6 % ça peut paraître peu
mais le risque dépend encore une fois du
contexte par exemple à l'automne dernier
des dizaines de personnes ont contracté
la maladie à la maison blanche
durant une cérémonie qui était pourtant
à l'extérieur mais les participants ont
passé plusieurs heures en contact
rapproché et plusieurs ne portait pas de
masque réduire le risque à zéro
et donc presque impossible même à
l'extérieur mais on peut le minimiser on
reste en poste sur place en gardant ses
distances en portant un masque et en
réduisant la durée de ses contacts
n'hésitez pas à nous envoyer vos
questions à l'adresse que vous voyez à
l'écran et nous on va y répondre le plus
rapidement possible